what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special to offer and
I love to see it explode
so that you can help change the planet
so to help you on your journey today
we're gonna look at seven different ways
that you can make business alliances so
one of the fastest ways to grow your
company is through alliances you find
people who are already selling to your
target market and instead of you having
to go one by one by one by one talking
to potential customers you want to be
able to talk to one person who then can
open you up to tens hundreds thousands
hundreds of thousands of customers and
so today we are going to talk about
seven different ways to be able to do
that way number one is to look at where
do people buy before they buy from you
so understand that buying is a cycle
people are not always ready to buy from
you people are not always ready to buy
from your potential Alliance partners
and there's a phase where you buy one
thing from somebody and then you
graduate and buy the next thing and buy
the next thing and so what you want to
look at is wherever you are in that
buying cycle you want to find all the
people that your customers are buying
from before they buy from you so as an
example if you are a graphic designer
you know you're a graphic designer and
you want to figure out the buying cycle
maybe before somebody buys graphic
design services they have built a
website or they've got hosting or they
you know just incorporated a business
and so all of those people here you want
to start making connections with you
want to take them out for lunch you want
to approach them grab a coffee
understand them and you want to learn
about their business and it's way easier
to set up a meeting with a potential
partner because you can help each other
out
much more than it is to make a cold call
and try to get a meeting with a customer
and so I'm trying to send these people
I'm trying to figure out how I can help
them if you get business that you could
potentially give to them that's great
right if you now and know somebody who
needs website design or hosting or
business set up you know you can refer
them to these people
and they'll so you're hoping that if you
make a good impression they
for business on to you and understand
that sometimes you need to work out a
relationship with with a commission or a
fee structure where you know they get a
flat amount if they refer you a client
or they get a percentage of a deal
therefore your client a lot of times
they do it just because it makes them
look good it's just it's a value-added
service if I'm a web hosting company and
I've just taken on a new client and I
know they need graphic design if I
introduce them to somebody who does a
great job it makes them look good so if
you do a great job for your clients
anybody that's been referred in it
actually makes that person look great as
well and you're gonna get a lot more
deals coming through so understand who
the people are that your clients are
buying from before they ever buy from
you get to know them take them to coffee
understand their business and try to
find a way to work together way number
two is understanding where people buy
from after they buy from you so we
understand where they're buying from
before obviously than they're buying
from us what's next
like who's out in this range so if I'm a
graphic designer and I'm making people a
beautiful business card but what's next
they're gonna need a printer so what I
want to do now is go and meet all of
these people because these are all
potential alliance partners for my
business as well I want to talk to all
the printers in my area I want to talk
to anybody who they're gonna then take
my graphic design services and do the
next step with I want to talk to those
people because again one it's easy to
make those meetings because there's
partnerships you can protect you help
both of each other out it gives you a
path to refer clients on to and then if
clients are coming to them and saying
hey I love your printing services but
before we use you we need to get a good
graphic design concept completed for our
business card right they can pass it on
to you right and then if you do a good
job then you make them look good so
again the same idea of do you want to
give them a commission a flat fee or
just just be able to pass the frills
back and forth and have that kind of
trusted relationship meeting with people
on both sides of the equation and
forming as many partnerships as you can
can really help explode your customer
base much faster than going after
customers one at a time
[Music]
we number three to make alliances is
through your customers a lot of times
your customers can be great conduits for
either becoming a business partner in
your company passing referrals on to you
doing a tighter kind of integration with
in my first software company we always
use our customers to fund our next
development so we had our base software
and then if a customer wanted a custom
feature built we would charge them for
like okay you want that thing added
great we can do it it's gonna cost you
this amount of money we would do it at
cost we wouldn't really make a ton of
profit off of that development but then
that feeds into our product that we can
sell to everybody and so anytime
customers wanted that custom integration
custom development we would do it and it
helps everybody else so they're helping
fund our business to grow on my You Tube
channel is an example when I wanted to
put on my book we reached out to number
you guys who had YouTube channels and
we're already part of the community
you guys are my customers and we're
doing some business development what to
see how we can help each other out and I
appeared on your channel you appeared on
my channels and so there's a lot of ways
to make it work if I look at Charlie
it's also as an example we look at the
companies that people work at and often
the students who come in then take the
message back to their company and they
tell their friends and they might put up
a sign in in the lunch area and help
promote the school talk about us on
social media you know so you want to
basically try to get as close to your
customers as possible you want to
understand why they came to you what
their needs are what they do for a
living what makes them tick what their
needs passions desires are and one that
just helps you get more referrals right
that if they know you like you trust you
they might tell their friends about you
but it could also lead to a greater
integration with what they're doing I
may lead to a tighter relationship with
the business that they're at more sales
more orders introductions up the line
when I had my software company another
quick example so we got one scientist at
Johnson & Johnson to buy our software
Johnson Johnson is a huge company they
have tons of scientists and so we want
to really get to know that person and
then see how can we use that person to
get introductions to the other
scientists and then you get all the
scientists in that one area then how do
you use those guys to leapfrog to
another area and so soon you're getting
more and more more and more
or the company now you can't do that
with every customer but the more you
understand each individual customer you
have then you can try to figure out is
there any kind of tighter relationship
that we can have to help grow this
business together tip number four is to
use social media so I wanted to build a
list of potential alliance partners the
first thing I did was to reach out to
people who are already familiar with me
I have a series called unlocking Lily on
this channel I reach out to people who
are commenting on my videos to do
possible collaborations the second thing
I did was to reach out to people who
have reviewed evans book or interviewed
him on their channel that way we have a
mutual interest as well and the third
thing that I did was to go through evans
videos and read the comments of the
people and there i looked at people's
comments that resonated with me and I
looked at their channel if they had an
about page I looked at what they were
about to see we aligned with our mission
and we could work well together from
there I was able to create my list of a
thousand names and I had some great
collaborations and even out of that I
made some great friends so to build
alliances on social media the number one
thing you want to do is to create a big
list mine was a thousand the more names
you have the more possibilities you'll
have number two is to find people that
already know you and who are already
following you and number three is to
find people who have similar interests
as you if there are certain videos that
you love to watch look at the people
commenting chances are they're on the
same mission as you
[Music]
the number 5 way is through your
suppliers think about all the people who
you're currently spending money with
people who you are paying on a regular
basis whether you're buying a product or
service from them and see if there might
be a way that they could help make
introductions for you to other people
that might help your business so an
easiest case example is looking at
lawyers accountants bookkeepers these
are people who deal with a lot of
different entrepreneurs a lot of
different kinds of businesses and so if
they know what your business is about
and they know the kinds of partnerships
that you're looking to make just letting
them know you know this is somebody who
you might be paying once a quarter maybe
once a year maybe more frequently if you
have more business but they have a
vested interest in helping their clients
come together and form greater
relationships because if you do that
then they're gonna make more business
right like you're gonna come back you
can get them referrals if you're looking
at people that you buy supplies from you
know if you're buying t-shirts from them
and you're put in a big order every
month buy t-shirts is there anybody that
they may know that could potentially
help your business like what is the kind
of Alliance partnership that you're
looking for in an ideal world and do
they have somebody that they can
introduce you to and so it doesn't hurt
to make a list of all your suppliers all
the people that you're spending money
with now if you're spending 30 bucks a
month on you know Verizon to get
Internet I'm here they're not gonna
really care about helping you want and
so the easier ones and when you're
dealing with a person you know an
entrepreneur or a physical salesperson
at a company and you have a relationship
with them learn to tighten that
relationship get to know them taking the
coffee you have a lunch with them
understand what they're after to and try
to figure out how you might people help
each other out suppliers can be a
fantastic alliance partnership for you
[Music]
we number six is through banks and
governments and I put these two together
because they're both low leverage
typically but it really just depends on
the person and so when I first got
started in my business I went to the
bank and I said hey I'd like some help
and said well do you need a loan like I
don't know if any alone I don't I just
got started on what I don't know what
I'm doing I need help and say well
that's not what banks really do uh-huh
but it was with somebody who was nice
enough who then put me onto somebody
else who became one of my first mentors
in my business so again banks see people
all day long who are potentially able to
make connections for you a lot of people
don't even know their banker it's a good
idea just in general to get to know who
your banker is because if you ever need
money if you're ever trying to get any
kind of debt facility that personal
connection makes a big difference but
they may also be able to refer you to
other clients that they have it again
really depends on the individual
sometimes individual bankers are really
friendly and really customer focus and
really driven to help their client
succeed other times bankers just want to
climb the ladder they hate this job they
want to move up to the next step they
don't really care about their clients
and so it makes it harder than form that
relationship
government on the other hand a lot of
governments have different programs in
place in in Toronto as an example we
have a group called Enterprise Toronto
it's funded by the city and there's
multiple locations here and you can walk
in and get help with your business they
have advisors who try to give you
feedback will help assess your business
plan they have multiple different
programs where you can apply for funding
and different opportunities but they
also try to connect you together if you
get to know the Resource Manager at
Enterprise Toronto they may have mentors
that they can connect you to they may
remember another entrepreneur that came
in last week that might be a good
potential fit for you and so it really
depends on what's happening in your city
you may be fortunate to have a lot of
great government programs you may have
nothing so that may not be a path for
you so I put banks and government
together because it really depends on
the circumstances and who you end up
being able to connect with but it's at
least worth exploring to see if there's
an opportunity for you to make an
alliance partnership
[Music]
and number seven my last way to former
lines partnerships is through targeted
events I've been looking at where my
ideal partners are hanging out what kind
of events are going to and go to those
events to get to know people so if
you're looking at making a partnership
with people who are you know techies who
are really into programming that you
want to have a custom development shop
as an alliance partner then you want to
hang out at the events that they care
about even if it's not super relevant to
you right like you may not care anything
about programming in the latest PHP
development and all the stuff that's
coming out you don't care anything about
that but they do and they're hanging out
there so you want to go there and get to
know them whether that's a conference
whether that's a meetup group whether
that's some local event that's happening
in your city if you know your target
partners marketing 101 if you know that
your target partners are going to be
there you want to be there to get to
know them and the advantage is of you
being there is a lot of tons of people
who are like you your competition is not
going to be there the people are going
to be there are more people like them
their competitors who they may not want
to talk to and do deals with but there's
outsider comes in and promoting this
different option that is potentially
complimentary to them you stand out in a
sea of similar nests and people will
want to talk to you and it's a
competitive advantage versus where you
might go like if you're a marketer you
go into marketing events you're like
everybody else there if the programmer
came there he would have an easier time
making those connections and so hanging
out is for talking to customers too but
hanging out where the people who you
want to talk to are even if it's outside
your comfort zone or where you would
normally go it's super important because
that's how you're gonna make the
connections so those are my seven tips
on how to form alliance partnerships
again forming alliances is one of the
fastest ways to grow your company
because you're thinking I want to target
one person or ten people or a group of
people who then can introduce me to tons
of people the goal is not to go up to
one customer one customer one customer
at a time it works but it's not very
efficient or effective we really talk to
the people who can make multiple
introductions for you you're much more
likely to
Piper explode your business so I'd love
to know what you think I'd love to know
which one resonated the most with you
that you're going to try and apply to
your business ASAP if you want to add an
8 9 10 to the list leave it down the
comments below I'd love to hear that too
now I made this video because I am Omar
asked me to so if there's a topic you'd
like me to cover on the future seven
ways video check out the link in
description go there cast your vote have
your say and I just might do it finally
I want to give a quick shout out to
Daniel from the lonely book in the air
Daniel thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word doing
the review posting it on your Instagram
channel I really preach it to support
man and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon